make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so as you guys know those individuals
who have been a part of my channel for a
while it is December which means we are
wrapping up old stories that we haven't
finished yet and we are we're covering
last night on earth
the end of book 1 we cover the first
three chapters and then never finished
the rest and and that's probably because
especially because of the fact that part
3 comes out in like ten days so yeah we
kind of need to cover this so getting
into Batman or I guess finishing up book
one of Batman last night on earth so
here's a deal here alright here's a
crazy thing about this this was
basically a story kind of playing
catch-up here this is a story where
Batman just kind of woke up right like
in this sort of asylum is this crazy
situation where we didn't know if Batman
was sane or insane it was kind of this
idea that it had been a sort of
repeating process over and over and over
again and then ultimately he left went
out into the world and then we basically
learned the world had essentially gone a
pot right we were in like some kind of
post-apocalyptic landscape he ultimately
stumbled across the Joker's head in a
jar
it was crazy things like that the idea
here is that we didn't know exactly what
was going on all we knew is that things
had seemingly gone south and so what we
ended up getting was basically Batman
and Joker kind of going forward to
whatever future happened you know they
happen to happen to be walking into you
and so what this does is it picks up
with the idea that as soon as they make
their way towards a town of sorts you
know Batman still in this straightjacket
that they're ultimately beset upon by
all these individuals who are wielding
Green Lantern rings but don't really
have any willpower now here's the crazy
thing about it but like initially in an
honest service when it comes to a Green
Lantern you have to be able to have
willpower to use the ring right if you
don't have enough willpower it's just a
ring on your finger you can't really do
anything with it right like willpower
powers the ring and so the result of
this is that under normal circumstances
these individuals whoever they are who
were almost just kind of like in a
zombified state would not be able to
wield the Rings but the way this worked
out is that it's somewhere along the
line then in this post-apocalyptic
landscape
Mogo showed up on earth now we can
largely assume that mobile was called by
the Green Lantern's of Earth so like
Kyle Rayner and Guy Gardner and Jon
Stewart and Hal Jordan and ultimately
Mogo was basically killed now the ways
explained by the Joker
Mogo was quote-unquote leached by
Brainiac what that means we don't fully
know presumably Brainiac just sucked the
life energy out of out of Mogo but we
don't really know to what ends instead
London up happening is that with the
deaths of these Green Lantern's and we
only see a few of them we only see three
right so the game basically it's kind of
the fact that there were only a handful
here on earth de RINs basically went out
to grab new bearers and presumably ended
up bonding to normal humans but they
lack the willpower to use them and so
with no real guiding force here with the
Green Lantern central power battery
basically destroyed or at least this
massive battery being destroyed what it
did is it really kind of led to a
scenario where the Rings went awry now
again it's kind of strange here because
we don't normally see it that way right
like a real would actually tell a person
you know you don't have the willpower to
use me and it would leave and go find
somebody else but what we're seeing here
is a landscape where presumably
everybody's dead right so whatever
individuals these are whatever whatever
they were capable of it's just kind of
these rings that seem to be going
without any real leadership or direction
and just sort of running awry
that's what makes it so kind of crazy
right that's what makes it so bonkers
it's because it's something that we
don't really normally see here now of
course Batman does his best to kind of
you know stay out of the fray with these
guys and not really kill anybody but
instead of being destroyed he's
ultimately rescued by vixen uh who ends
up of course grabbing him and yanking
him into an invisible truck now of
course those are guys who are unfamiliar
with vixen she taps into the red which
is basically the animal equivalent of
the green the power that uh that the
swampthing uses essentially she can
channel the abilities of animals but
ultimately she's there alongside poison
ivy and a handful of others respect the
question why are heroes and villains
working together which is something we
don't normally see and so Batman
essentially just kind of picks up inside
this cave inside this giant geode
alongside Supergirl with poison ivy and
vixen and it's it's kind of wild to see
because then suddenly Wonder Woman makes
her appearance carrying the the helmet
of doctor fate only for us to find out
magic does is is long gone Magic's
basically dead and so whatever has
happened on this world pretty much all
the heroes and all the villains are
essentially gone and it's kind of wild
right I mean what what you see here is
really what you get there really isn't
anybody left like it's all basically
kind of dashed to pieces and so when the
question is asked how did this world end
up the way it is we finally get this
explanation here it's not super in-depth
sky senado kind of teases us but we give
this explanation where Wonder Woman
basically ends up saying that there was
this great big huge debate that took
place between Lex Luthor and Superman
and in this debate Lex Luthor seemingly
convinced the world that like
superheroes aren't needed right now this
is interesting and this is actually one
of the coolest takes on Lex Luthor this
is the reason why I always tell you guys
villains are usually more interesting
than the heroes and this is perfectly in
line with something that Lex Luthor
would do right Lex Luthor's greatest
weapon is as mine arguably he's a smart
person on earth I want to say it kind of
goes back and forth between himself and
and Batman sometimes mr. terrific but
for the most part it's it's really just
kind of like you know Lex Luthor and
Batman in terms of the smartest people
in the world with regards to like normal
humans and so as a result of that when
he engaged in this debate he essentially
convinced the world you don't really
need superheroes anymore like you don't
need two superheroes to protect you that
there's no real basis for them and where
initially the victory seemed to go to
Luthor a humanity ended up turning on
villains as well as a humanity kind of
took it into their own hands now this is
intriguing and I find this really cool I
find it's really really interesting here
right the notion that humanity would sit
down one day and say yeah you're right
we don't need heroes like we're just
going to basically take over and we're
gonna eliminate heroes and villains now
the issue that you run into in any
scenario like this because it looks like
a massive war broke out between all the
heroes and the villains possibly against
humanity whatever the case happened to
be that a massive conflict broke out and
what it led what it led to was this
complete and total breakdown of
organized society throughout the world
or within just the United States we're
not really given a definitive answer
we're really kind of told it's the world
but we only get it within the confines
and the view of Batman so it's like you
know it's one of these things where I
guess I could kind of go either way
especially because everything in this
story is so crazy but what ended up
happening here is with the fall of of
society you ended up getting kind of
like this rise of petty warlords and so
because of that it was it looks like
it's one of these scenarios where
humanity really just just seemed to like
have soft superheroes and villains with
no thought to what came next and so
without any real heroes and villains
then it suddenly turned into individuals
who were vying for power and so with
this sort of you know breaking down in
complete degradation of society
you got this rise of like strongmen and
petty warlords all over the place who
were trying to vie for power and trying
to control their own little sections of
the country which ultimately led to the
rise of this villain called Omega now
for Omega it's very much a mystery here
like omegas wielding the head of
Darkseid right so whoever it is seems to
be powerful enough to have killed
Darkseid but you're talking about like
the deaths of magic wielders in DC
you're talking about the deaths of
pretty much all the superheroes - a
handful ah the question remains like
where is Superman you know for those of
you guys who are ahead of this please
don't spoil anything but the question is
like where's Superman I mean it's it's
it's all these these interesting
scenarios when Superman is perceived to
have been dead is the indication from a
Wonder Woman says Superman's dead and
gone like he's he's out of the picture
now and is really kind of interesting
here because the question is like well
what happened like
how could this have happened we end up
learning that like Batman was a part of
it you know that that that from what
Wonder Woman says Batman's the one who
killed the world it's kind of wild you
know when in this this whole scenario
the Batman seems to have been the cause
or at least seems to have been a major
figure in the death of the world and so
what she basically says here this is
really one of the darker elements of the
story what she says here is that that
one woman has really kind of facilitated
a deal between Hades and herself and
what this would do is it would allow all
those you know whatever individuals were
left a hundred thousand people who were
basically left that are residing
alongside Wonder Woman to essentially
travel deeper in into the realm of Hades
where there's virtually no light
whatsoever and they would imagine that
they be able to attain some little bit
of light but essentially they would just
be individuals living in like you know
pitch-black caves down below and in you
know the core of the earth kind of in
the realm of Hades itself and so it's a
really bleak and dark outcome here right
like it's one of these things were
square Snyder's like yeah like there's
no there's no good future here there's
no real good place for them to go the
world's dead right I mean the world is
essentially conquered and that's
basically yet and it's kind of nuts
because Omega leads that section but
like humanity as they're being found or
essentially being either eradicated or
being forced into the into the realm of
Omega because he basically managed to
discover the anti-life equation and is
using it to dominate people right so
living down in in the realm of Hades
where there's virtually no light in this
pitch-black environment seems to be a
better alternative than living on the
surface and obviously probably not right
I mean if you have to live your life in
such and such a degree it might be
better to just kind of go out swinging
right I mean you just go up to the
service and take your chances and hope
for the best but it's kind of a crazy
theme because what she says is the world
will always need a Batman this place
always needs Batman we need your mind we
need your your your ingenuity we need
you here with us and so she basically
reveals to him of course the Batman suit
and it's one of these funny things
because as we know from the the previous
stories this version of Batman is not
really Batman right it's a clone that's
constantly created over the years over
time because every generation would need
a Batman the Oh Bruce Wayne sat down one
day and realized that the time would
come and he would no longer be able to
be bad weather because he was killed
prematurely or because he was too old to
fight or whatever the case is but like
every generation would need a Batman so
kind of engine engineering these clones
more or less of himself that had all of
his resources abilities his mind so on
and so forth could continue his role as
Batman presumably until the end of time
and that's the response of her is like
we let Alfred go through with that
because we felt bad for him but like
you're here now and you should stay here
with us
response of Bruce is like that's
ridiculous though like this state to go
down to the realm of Hades where there's
like no light whatsoever to leave them
into someplace where it's just darkness
and despair like how can that possibly
be better than living on the surface and
the response of one woman is well
because we're not guaranteed to die but
is any real measure of a life at all but
is it any real real world to live in and
so ultimately what is up happening here
and in really kind of a cool moment here
what is up happening is Batman of course
has a bit of a conversation with the
Joker and a conversation is a loose term
Joker keeps trying to reach hell this
joke over and over again and keeps
forgetting it and so basically he says
like it's time for us to go one of them
one basically shows up you know to where
Batman was supposed to be wrestling only
to find out that Bruce Wayne essentially
left he took the back soon he left the
area and is basically just kind of out
there right - sort of out there going
back out into the world with the Joker
presumably to try to save it or to try
to do something to fix it but all
indications point to the fact that there
is no fixing this world this world is
dead it's gone it's beyond hope it's
cool this is a really really amazing
story what happen he said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here - comments explain and make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace alright so as promised our
shoutouts for the producers of the
comics explained videos our patrons I
want to give a shout out to Jason see
Austin s Jason s Austin H Phillip and
Austin B we have a lot of Austin's and
our patreon as well as G gnosis 916 de
gnosis didn't give us the first and last
name so we kinda had to roll with it I
didn't mention your last names but I
want to say thank you to you all by the
way your rob4 rings should be on their
way for our honor guard members of the
Rob core for these special patrons your
custom Rob core rings should be on their
way they're being shipped to me after
that I will have them shipped to you
stay tuned keep your eye on patreon and
your messages and you will hear about
them coming to you thank you
[Music]